aquí
[Música]
volvemos con ustedes para una nueva
entrevista en cinco minutos con maría
isabel es sedano abogado de los hijos de
dos mujeres fallecidas por
esterilizaciones forzadas en perú
hablamos con ella a propósito que ya
iniciaron los juicios por más de mil
denuncias similares en el marco de una
campaña de planificación familiares del
ex presidente alberto fujimori en los
años 90 bienvenida a maría isabel y perú
inicia una de sus citas judiciales más
importantes en la historia reciente del
país 16 años pasaron y por fin se
revisan estas denuncias de violación de
derechos humanos que representa el caso
para usted y porque es de suma
importancia
el caso es emblemático porque durante el
gobierno de fujimori fueron
esterilizadas más de 300.000 mujeres en
su mayoría quechuahablantes campesinas
indígenas amazónicas andinas en
situación de pobreza al estado peruano
no le interesó el derecho a decidir de
estas mujeres y después de 16 años de
investigación fiscal preliminar que
empezó el 2002 el ministerio público les
creyó y presentó denuncia ante el poder
judicial en noviembre del 2018 han
pasado dos años y hemos tenido que estar
en las calles junto con las víctimas y
sobrevivientes para que se pueda llegar
a la audiencia de sustentación de cargos
que se realizó el lunes 11 de enero
según la defensoría del pueblo entre el
96 y el 2001 fueron más de 272 mil
operaciones de ligadura de trompas y
22.000 vasectomías no se conoce sin
embargo cuántas de ellas se llevaron a
cabo mediante engaños y mediante
coacciones a las personas qué datos
tienen ustedes sobre las víctimas
a las víctimas se les violó el derecho
al consentimiento previo libre e
informado y por escrito que corresponde
en los métodos anticonceptivos
irreversibles según los estándares
internacionales de derechos humanos
porque porque cuando se ejecutó el
programa de salud reproductiva y
planificación familiar entre el 96 y el
en la primera etapa de dicho programa no
existía ni siquiera la
hoja el formulario para prestar dicho
consentimiento con determinadas
características no se garantizó el
derecho a traducción en la lengua
original para que las mujeres puedan
comprender y dar un consentimiento libre
tampoco se les dio plazo razonable y
muchas fueron intervenidas en
condiciones precarias e insalubres que
condujeron a la muerte dada la gravedad
de todas estas acusaciones que es lo que
usted como abogada y las víctimas
esperan que el estado haga con este caso
junto con milton campos formamos el
equipo legal de demos para poder
representar los derechos de al mansur
salazar mestanza hijo menor de mamérita
mestanza cuyo caso llegó a la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos y el
estado peruano reconoce a través de la
firma del acuerdo de solución amistosa
en el año 2003 que violó derechos
humanos en el marco del programa de
salud reproductiva y planificación
familiar también representamos a las
hijas de seria ramos otra víctima mortal
de la política fujimorista nosotras
estamos exigiendo que el juez rafael
martín martínez haga una investigación
judicial rápida y bien hecha no como
pasó el lunes que no garantizaron el
derecho a traducción de las víctimas y
eso fue usado por el abogado de fujimori
para poder dilatar y distraer
este proceso nos queda menos de un
minuto y le quiero preguntar ya para
terminar cuál es la responsabilidad del
ex presidente fujimori que además no
estuvo presente en la audiencia inicial
y es que aquí estamos hablando de que a
mujeres y hombres se les quitó el
derecho a decidir sobre la potestad para
dar vida
una familia para planificar la familia
para decidir cuántos hijos tener e hijas
tener bueno el ex presidente fujimori y
sus ex ministros de salud eduardo yo no
está marino costa bauer alejandro y
nadie entre otros funcionarios están
denunciados por delitos graves seguidos
de muerte y lesiones graves en contextos
de graves violaciones a los derechos
humanos que son imprescriptibles es la
primera oportunidad que después de 18
años de iniciado la este proceso penal
un juez va a escuchar a las víctimas y
va a determinar la responsabilidad de
cada uno de estos coautores de dicho
crimen de lesa humanidad muchas gracias
a ustedes y tenemos que continuar en
france 24 nos vemos más adelante
[Música]